a Las Vegas mother says School leaders
need to be held accountable for
expelling her daughter thanks for
staying with us here at 6 30 I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus now the
teenager was accused of hitting an
administrator but an investigation
revealed that never happened 8 news now
reporter Joshua peguero explains
for more than two months a Rome Reese's
11 year old daughter missed school time
her mother says she can't get back it
wasn't a fight within his final
investigation this young lady was not
the one that struck the assistant prison
that was the opening statement for a
hearing Shiro ma Reese attended on April
5th regarding her daughter's expulsion a
sixth grader at sedway Middle School on
January 30th she was kicked out all
based on an accusation she hit an
assistant principal well I didn't
understand the decision how she got put
up for this motion Rhys says she fought
hard to have her daughter reinstated I
don't understand the whole point of the
hearing if they already had a decision
they already knew would happen I feel
like they were just trying to cover it
up the matter caused emotional distress
for Reese's family her daughter enrolled
in setaways a special education program
had an IEP which required she get extra
attention Visa Services she couldn't
receive for the two months she was out
how can I go to work if my child is
still out of school and if I leave her
here that's another way for me to go to
jail last week Reese received a citation
in the mail charging her daughter with
fighting an advocate on behalf of Reese
Camilla bywaters spoke at the hearing it
was really concerning that on her
incident report it was the incident a
charging battery I'm not sure what that
looks like but that accusation of
battery and then we come here to find
out today that
she didn't even she's not the one who
hit the assistant principal Reese's
daughter has dreams of becoming a doctor
dreams that could be impacted they
filled her tremendously what's not clear
at this time is who made that accusation
that Reese's daughter struck the
assistant principal and if that person
will face discipline for the student
missing so much time from school back to
you guys Joshua good reporting there
well it reached out he did reach out to
the district and they say they don't
comment on student privacy matters